the ghosts of Minnie Quay I'm from I'm
from Michigan and actually grew up very
close to the port in Iran and so I would
love to think that that was true so I'm
gonna say it's true Michigander come on
the chartreuse lady although it sounds
like a wonderful drink haunting a
brothel I want to believe it's true and
yet something seems too convenient I'm
gonna say false
the sailing Frenchman that sounds like a
filthy sexual practice Mariners have
lots of folklore about their ships and
things that get them through the rough
seas so I'm gonna I'm gonna say that the
sailing Frenchman is true please let it
be true Oh nuts The Greenbrier goes I
think that there's such a folklore and
such a big story behind said ghost I
think that there's a lot of legal
reasons why these ghost exists on I'm
gonna say true come on three four four
right
the wizard clip that's why I used to get
my hair cut when I was good that's such
a bizarre sounding name for a ghost and
story behind it that I'm gonna say it's
true hmm the lady of the stacks I like
the sound of her but she sounds too much
like somebody who was in the original
Ghostbusters so I'm gonna say false hi
he can't boo me Oh Joe Bush where are
you this election season why would I
possibly want Joe pushing off Joe Bush I
feel like minors and then people who
work with the earth have a folklore
about it and some sort of mysteries so
let's say Joe Bush is true no by the
hair which hair which who died in using
a dryer in the bathtub
that's stupid enough that you should
Emma being a ghost but I'm gonna say
that's false oh you did it huh come on
what was my score